décembre 2010 est la première à halle
était alors en cours de construction
elle est aujourd'hui opérationnel sur ce
terrain de 12 hectares qui borde le
lavoir des chavannes
cet atelier est la première réalisation
concrète du meca team cluster autrement
dit le pôle de compétences spécialisées
dans la conception la construction et la
maintenance d'engins de travaux
ferroviaires
l'atelier fait 100 m 100 m de long et il
a été imaginé et le cahier des charges a
été fait par les directeurs de matériel
de plusieurs entreprises de travaux
ferroviaires pour pour trouver la
solution idéale l'atelier idéal
donc voilà il était fait en commun comme
tout ce qui est organisé par mecha team
kloster le l'origine de mecha think le
star c'est de trouver les meilleures
solutions pour la filière ferroviaire
près de 80 acteurs sont rassemblés dans
ce pôle de compétences collectivités
territoriales activités de recherche
mais aussi bien sûr de nombreux acteurs
de la filière les plus gros comme vinci
ou eiffage possède déjà ce type
d'atelier mais ils sont situés en région
parisienne et sont désormais engorgé et
puis il y à de plus petits opérateurs
qui profiteront désormais d'un outil
performant ce qu'on cherche à faire
c'est de rendre le service le même
service aux grands groupes qu'aux
petites entreprises c'est donner des
moyens aux petites entreprises aussi
qu'elles ne pourraient pas se payer seul
et puis il y à la formation le premier
centre français de formation aux métiers
de la maintenance ferroviaire est déjà
opérationnel depuis un an à montceau
mais il va bientôt quitter son algeco
pour beaucoup mieux demain c'est des
bâtiments en dur en fait que l'on voit
qui vont émerger salles de travaux
pratiques salles de classe et engins
réforme et qui vont permettre aux fesses
aux stagiaires de se former directement
sur du matériel avec toutes les
structures d'accueil qui vont venir la
sncf sous traitants massivement la
maintenance ferroviaire
autant dire que des opérations mutualisé
comme celles ci sont promises
un bel avenir